the cryptocurrency market suffered a
sharp sell-off on wednesday its value
has now tumbled
by 47 the last 10 days the market cap
for global digital currencies came in at
1.35 trillion
on wednesday down from a peak of 2.56
trillion on may 12th the most recent
plunge was triggered by the people of
bank of china announcement that digital
tokens can't be used as a formal payment
by financial institutions
bitcoin at one point fell as much as 31
percent to 30 000
while ethereum slipped by 44 to 1900
bitcoin still hasn't recovered from elon
musk climate related
concerns over its mining process which
sent shockwaves across the digital
asset ecosystem however having said that
having said that today today i think
bitcoin
bitcoin is back up what bitcoin is back
up 21
ethereum's back up so they're making
some kind of a progress aerium
almost at an all-time high wasn't there
all-time high it was at an all-time high
2800 and they're like right 26 50 or
something this morning no i don't know
where they're at right now but
all i know is it dropped to a uh
all-time the last seven days it dropped
to 1918 and i think at the peak it was 3
300 i think 3 300 was the number the
what are audience thoughts about what's
going on i think distribution is at play
here
any if you have distribution you've got
places to sell
and what china just said sorry we're
closing the market so no consumers
um so therefore they lose distribution
and
you know when you have outlets you have
everything when remember in the
beginning when dish network
and tesla and people said we're going to
take bitcoin now you've got distribution
you've got
you know this is why diners club what's
diners club it's a dead credit card
right
american express you know the sticker on
the window american express
accepted here mastercard visa that was
the war and credit cards going through
the 80s
and distribution was everything and
what's happening right now crypto's
going down because
there's not outlets that'll accept it
the value
the relative value is going to go down
in terms of you know yeah
spendability and so i think china and
um oh also um tesla said hang on a
second
we're not going to take uh bitcoin for a
while maybe it's power reasons
but i think there's a lot of
distribution if it's available and
trading
and it's it's in your paypal it's in
your coinbase and you can use it
anywhere
it's got more value and i think what
they have this week is a
social thing on the mining and the
electricity but also
on distribution china saying made in
china don't use a bitcoin
adam what do you think well i agree with
tom there's uh two major stories
that moved the markets this week number
one was china for sure everything you
just said
about basically they're not being able
to
uh make payments and then number two
obviously we've touched on this with
elon musk everything that he did
since his snl appearance everything that
he did to basically dismantle
the belief in dogecoin everything so but
i think this is good
i think this is good to have a shake-up
in the market like this because there's
basically two types of people
there's the hodlers that have been
holding bitcoin since
2012 2015 2017 whenever they got in
they've been
holding and then there's the speculators
who have been just kind of
you know along for the ride and if you
got in
basically this year because think about
it and you've touched on this the last
time we spoke
how many people got a stimulus check and
pumped it right into the markets or
bitcoin or a lot of young people
not a younger base right so when all you
know is up and nothing ha
you know you bought in at 15 or 20 and
you got to 60
and you put in 10 grand and now you got
50 grand whatever the number is
um you think this is a magical bitcoin
ride like a aladdin magic carpet ride
but the reality is markets go up markets
go down
assets go up assets go down so it's
basically a lesson of how much you can
stomach
so i did an episode on the episode on
bitcoin when it reached the trillion
dollar market cap
um about basically
what the big boys are doing you know ftm
follow the money what are the big boys
doing tesla at the time and other
companies in that realm were putting
three to eight percent of their cash
reserves into crypto okay cool so use
that
as an example as set for your marker as
a marketer
all right so the big boys are getting
five bucks to put 30 to 80 degrees oh
whatever
but that i did i did interview a bunch
of people at a crypto conference i'm 99
crypto i'm all in on krypto yeah i don't
use cash anymore yeah
okay well i hope you can stomach a 40
drop a 30
drop a 20 drop in a week so it's a base
basically you're 22 what's what's what
is a 22 year old worried about if you're
25 yeah
if you're 45 with kids with a family and
you're
99 crypto it's a gamble right and it's a
pretty big gamble well you know this
everything when it comes to investments
comes down to asset allocation
by the way somebody just said ethereum
was a 40 i want to be very accurate here
folks
we said 3 300. tom threw me off the
highest ethereum's bin is let me look it
says 4 300.
so continue you were saying no basically
you know you you worked uh
uh what was your first job when 9 11 you
were with um morgan center morgan
stanley okay gotcha so you started off
in the investment 4165
all-time high they teach you about asset
allocation and a diversified portfolio
and the 80 20 you know
balanced portfolio 80 stocks 20 bonds
whatever it is and then there's the
the three fund portfolio where you've
got you know your s p
and then you got your international and
then you've got your bonds what have you
in my opinion crypto does need to be a
part of your portfolio at this point
and it's just about how much you can
stomach so for me
five percent is my number right cool
i'll put in this i'll put in that but
for the most part i'm all in on
the s p and and what have you so you
just got to ask yourself
how much you're willing to stomach with
this crypto ride because it was at 60
grand now it's at 30 grand this is all
within a month or two
um but i think one thing for for sure
that you you said this the other day
is blockchain here to stay yeah it's not
going away is bitcoin here to stay
yes is are nfts here to stay
yes it's just establishing you know the
market value of these things yeah the
price point the
the the real argument that is made
sometimes is it an investment if it's a
currency is it something that you put in
and say hey this is a form of an
investment or currency it's a different
topic there right
if a currency is being treated like a
stock it's kind of weird if a currency
is being treated like a stock
that hey i'm going to invest into you
don't say i'm going to invest
into i understand there is a a
big you gotta foreign but forex guys
don't make
you know 350 in the last 12 months you
don't hear a number like that right if
you do it's
typically you're you're a little bit of
lucky and some stuff you got going on
that's the only challenge you see with
this
by the way uh the other day uh edward
stone i don't know if you saw what he
said
he said the the best the best thing they
could do for bitcoin is to keep it
private not keep it public
that's that's what it was built for it
wasn't built to be public it was built
to be private
and to him he says i'm a holder i have
crypto
i'm in with this i'm part of the group
but i don't like the fact that it's
public i want it to be private
why is he saying that actually go to why
he's saying that maybe long term he's
worried about regulation
maybe long term he's sitting there
saying man yeah yeah you're sitting
there saying dude this was created not
for me to be a billionaire this was
created for me to be private
for me to keep my life private now
everything is public everybody can find
it i don't want it to be public i want
it to be private
so there's there's can and when edward
snowden says something like that i mean
the guy's got access to attention people
kind of pay attention to it so
my biggest concern has been the same
it's not changed you're just seeing how
volatile it is and
quite frankly for those guys that are
you know going along on it if you
dollar cost average at 30 000 goes back
to 64. you just doubled
if you believe in dollar cost averaging
if you don't you're part of another
community that's anti-bitcoin you're
sitting there saying i told you so i
told you so
everyone has at this point for the last
quarter
everyone can say i told you so if you're
on the
i love it to be honest with you the more
that i told you so is for the people
that are in the crypto community i
totally agree
yeah and i'm totally and i'm not part of
that community i'm not part of that
community i'm
right in the middle i have very little
in it right but i'm right in the middle
yeah
but i respect their opinion and how they
uh uh
you know are true believers and what
they're doing so we're gonna see what's
gonna happen totally agree pat for the
last six months the crypto guy is gonna
sit back and be like
i told you so but for the last week or
two the people
you know the peter shifts of the world
who are like no way this is crazy this
is too volatile
this is uh speculative speculative
they can kind of say i told you so so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye